oprah winfrey went from being born into
poverty in rural mississippi to a
teenage single mother to becoming the
most
influential woman in the world she was
the richest african-american of the 20th
century and north america's first black
multi-billionaire she's currently worth
three billion dollars and takes a salary
of 75 million
per year need motivation watch a top 10
with believe nation what's up believe
nation it's evan i believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine
so let's get your motivation to attend
and have you believing in you
here's my take on oprah winfrey's top 50
rules for success
also if you want to know what oprah
winfrey and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 254
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days i will send you a
morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
key to success is what you believe
is true for yourself your number one job
is to become more
of yourself figure out
where your power base is
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one understand the right next move
the way through the challenge is to get
still
and ask yourself what is the next right
move
not think about oh i got all of this
what is the next
right move and then from that space make
the next right move
and the next right move and not to be
overwhelmed by it because
you know your life is bigger than that
one moment you know you're not defined
by
what somebody says is a failure for you
because failure is just there to point
you in a different direction
rule number two seize your opportunity
nothing about my life is lucky
nothing a lot of grace
a lot of blessings a lot of
divine order but i don't believe in luck
[Music]
for me luck is preparation meeting the
moment of opportunity
there is no luck without you being
prepared
to handle that moment of opportunity
and so what i would say for myself is is
that
because of my hand in a hand
and a force greater than my own i have
been prepared in ways that i didn't even
know i was being prepared
for and the truth is for me
and for every person
every single thing that has ever
happened in your life
is preparing you for the moment that is
to come
rule number three everyone makes
mistakes
you don't have to hold yourself hostage
to who you used to be
or anything you ever used to do because
who has lived and hasn't made mistakes
when i think about my 20s and what a
foolish girl i was
and how i would give over my power
to men who really didn't mean me well
but now i hold no grudges against them
either because i realized
i'm the one who gave over the power
because i didn't know any better
and now that i know better i know i
don't have to do that again
it's one of the most powerful lessons
any of us can ever know rule number four
work on yourself i say to the my girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out where
your power base is and to work on
the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason
why you're here that's that's the number
one thing you
have to do is to work on yourself
and to fill your self up
and keep your cup full keep yourself
full
now i used to be afraid of that i used
to be afraid particularly from people
who say oh she said she's so full of
hassan
she's so close herself and now i
embrace it i i consider it a compliment
that i am full of myself
because you only when you're full i'm
full i'm overflowing my cup run is over
i have so much i have so much to offer
and so much to give
and i am not afraid of honoring
myself you know it's miraculous when you
think about it
rule number five run the race as hard as
you can
i would say to my team well it doesn't
matter because every season somebody
else was coming out
one talk show two two talk shows three
structures there have been over 100 talk
shows since we started
but every time i would feel like all
right gotta step up our game
got to step up our game the way you step
up your game is not to worry about the
other guy
in any situation because you can't
control the other guy
you cannot control the other guy you
only have control over yourself
so it's like running a race the energy
that it takes to look back and see where
the other guys are takes energy away
from you and if they're too close
it scares you so that's what i would say
to my team all the time don't waste your
time in the race looking back to see
where the other guy is or what the other
guy is doing
it's not about the other guy it's about
what can you do you just need to
run that race as hard as you can you
need to give it
everything you've got all the time for
yourself
rule number six believe my grandmother
was a maid that's all she ever knew
the only real expectation she held for
me was that i would one day
become a maid and in her words have some
good white folks
meaning people who would not uh speak
negatively about me
who would allow me to take food home who
would be good to me
would treat me with some level of
dignity and respect
that was my grandmother's dream for me
but i had another dream for myself
another
more than a dream i had a belief for
myself
and i remember watching her
hang out clothes on a line one day and
say to me you have to watch me open gail
because one day you'll have to do this
for yourself
and knowing inside myself that that was
not going to be my life
don't know how i knew it other than
that thing that we all have intuition or
an instinct that said
no this will not be my life but because
i
sensed that and was connected to that
and i remember it was a very
still moment it was quiet
and i was still and i was watching her i
could see her right now with the
clothes pins in her mouth and putting
them on the line and seeing the breath
uh because it was cold the moisture
coming from her lips
and i knew that that would not be my
life i knew that i will not be hanging
clothes on a line
in a backyard in mississippi so i was
either four or five years old
and that belief that that would not be
my life is what i held on to for the
longest of times
i just no matter what believed
that there was something bigger greater
more for me rule number seven we are all
seeking the same thing i always
understood that there really was no
difference between me and the audience
at times i might have had better shoes
but at the core
the core of of what really matters
that we are the same you know how i know
that because
all of us are seeking the same thing
you're here at this fabulous school
and will go out into the world and each
pursue
based upon what you believe your talents
are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are
but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill
the highest truest expression
of yourself as a human being
that's what you're looking for the
highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being
and because i understand that i
understand that if you're working in a
bakery
and that's where you want to be and that
may be that that may be what you've
always wanted to do is to bake
pies for people or bake cakes for people
or to offer your gift
then then that's that's for you and
there's no difference between you and me
except that's how that's your platform
that's your show every day so my
understanding of that
has allowed me to you know everyone to
reach everyone
and and there's no way that you wouldn't
because that's that's what i
truly feel rule number eight find your
purpose
a lot of people don't know their purpose
and if you don't know your purpose
your immediate goal is to figure that
out
because otherwise you're just wandering
around here so the moment you can figure
out what it is you're supposed to be
doing
the sooner you are able to get about the
business of doing that rule number nine
stay grounded my life is fueled by my
being
and the being fuels the doing so i come
from a
centered place i come from a focused
place
i come from compassion
um it's just my nature i come from
a willingness to understand and to be
understood
and i come from wanting to to
to connect i mean the secret of that
show for 25 years
is that people could see themselves in
me
all over the world they could see
themselves in me
and even as i became
more and more financially successful
which was a big surprise to me i was
like oh my god this is so
exciting um you mean you got more than
that thirty thousand i got more than
thirty
thousand by the time i was thirty so
so my but what i realized
is through the whole process because i'm
grounded
in my own self
that although i could have more shoes
my feet stayed on the ground although i
was wearing better shoes these are kind
of cute today too
so i could keep my feet on the ground
even though i could get more shoes
and i could understand i could
understand that it really was
because i was grounded i've done the was
doing and
continue to this day to do the
consciousness
work i work at staying awake
rule number 11 be authentic i think that
success is a process
and i believe that my first
easter speech in the kosciuszko baptist
church
at the age of three and a half was was
the beginning
and that every other speech every other
book i read
every other time i spoke in public was
was a building block so that by the time
i first
sat down to audition in front of a
television camera
and somebody says read this what allows
me to read it so comfortably and be so
at ease
with myself at that time was the fact
that i'd been doing in a while if i'd
never read a book
like never spoken in public before i
would have been traumatized by it so
um the fact that um we went on the air
with the oprah winfrey show in 1980
nationally and people say oh but you're
you're
god you're so comfortable in front of
the camera you can be yourself well it's
because i've been being myself
since i was 19. and i would not have i
would not have been able to be as
comfortable with myself
had i not made mistakes on the air
and been allowed to make mistakes on the
air
and understand that it doesn't matter
you know i
there's no such thing to me as an
embarrassing moment no such thing
if i tripped and fell if my bra strap
showed if my slip
fell off if i fell flat on my face
there's no such thing as an embarrassing
moment because i know that there is not
a moment
that i could possibly experience on the
air
that somebody else hasn't already
experienced so when it happens you say
uh my slip fell off
and it's it's no big deal i mean like i
was on tv the other day and somebody
says
oh oprah you have a run have you not
seen a run before in your life well i
get them too let me tell you
so i mean i can't be embarrassed i can't
be embarrassed
now when i first started out that was
not true
because i was under the i was pretending
to be somebody i was not i was
pretending to be barbara walters
so i'd go to a news conference and i was
more interested in
how i phrased the question and how
eloquent the question
sounded as opposed to listening to the
answer
which always happens when you're
interested in impressing people instead
of doing what you're supposed to be
doing
and it took me a while it took me
messing up on the air
on during a live newscast i
was doing a list of foreign countries
and i there was all these foreign names
and then canada was thrown in
and i called canada canada and i got so
tickled that i called ken
i go that wasn't canada that was canada
excuse me that wasn't canada that was
that was in kanata that was canada and
then i started laughing
well it was it was it became a became
the first real moment i ever had
and um the news director later said to
me well if you do that then you should
just keep going you shouldn't correct
yourself and let people out
well i know well who's ever heard of
kanata so
that was for me the beginning of
realizing that oh
you can laugh at yourself and you can
make a mistake and it's not the end of
the world you don't have to be perfect
and uh biggest lesson for me for
television because then it didn't matter
it didn't matter oh sorry bra strap
showing rule number 12
do it all what inspired me was um
an is continues to be what continues to
inspire me
is a primal and fundamental desire
to fulfill the highest expression
of myself as a human being
i don't want to die
not having completely
burnt out every single
possibility of my humanity
i just i just want to when i leave this
planet i want everybody
did that used it all up not another
thing i could do
there wasn't another person i could have
given of myself to
there wasn't another deed i could have
done there wasn't anything that you just
wanna you wanna say
i want to fill it up you wanna take this
whole human existence which when you
think about it godfrey is really pretty
damn miraculous it is it is it is when
you think about what it means to be a
human being
on the planet earth right now that's
pretty awesome
so i just want to i wanted i want to
take that to the max
i want to say no need to come back as a
human
angel status rule number 13 love more
i know you hate this phrase but what is
your brand do you think oh
i'm the love brand oh we're all darling
no
i'm the lover i'm the love brand you
like to
shower love around and yeah it's really
that's what it is
i am the love and connection brand
that's what i want you a bit like barry
white was the love god you're the
love brand i'm the love brand because
ultimately
everything that i'm saying whether it's
in my magazine
whether it's uh gail on the radio
whether it's
the oprah winfrey show and now
everything about
the channel own it's about opening
your space your heart space so that you
can love more you know
that's really all money is for money is
worth nothing if it can't buy you
the opportunity to love more rule number
14
always give your best you can't call in
sick
you can't ever give less than 100
percent and if you are sick which i have
been a couple of times
that's when you got to pull up to 110
120
because people have come from all over
the country and this is their moment
they've saved their money they bought
the airline tickets
they got new outfits they call their
sisters their cousins their aunts
their mother-in-laws their mothers and
that is
why they're there to see you so i feel
a sense of responsibility a sense of
obligation
a sense of respect reverence honor for
those people
rule number 15 you are what you believe
first day i went to school i was in a
classroom
by the time i was uh you know six years
old didn't go to school i was six years
old because i lived my grandmother at
that time
but she had taught me how to read read
the bible bible stories
so i went into the classroom knowing
nicodemus
shadrach meshach and abednego i could
spell all of those words
i thought i was you know i was preaching
to the to my kindergarten teacher
so she was like who is this girl
so i was never placed in an environment
where i was ever made to feel inferior
i always felt like i'm the smartest kid
in this room
and because i was never placed in a
never put in a position
where i was made to feel less than i
didn't grow up
feeling less than you know and the rest
as they say is history
and the rest they say is history and
it's all about what you believe you know
i say this to
uh when i do something on my network now
called life class
the fundamental key to success
is what you believe is true for yourself
not what you want not what you desire
it's what do you believe
you know you can say i wanted i want to
be the most successful person in the
world
but if you believe that there's a glass
ceiling and you're going to have a hard
time
kicking through that glass ceiling you
will be
ceiling and um the great beauty and gift
of my life is that i was never
defined by the box that other people
tried to put me in
rule number 16 find your core self
fame comes with the mission and purpose
you know you cannot define me
or try to put me in a box and
you can't look at my life unless you
look at the whole life
so i am a negro
formerly born in 1954
in mississippi at a time when it was an
apartheid
state and
to be sitting here with you as your
first
guest in 2011 is a miracle
that is beyond anything i could actually
do for myself
so there's something greater at at work
here
and the thing that's greater at work um
the force that has enforces that have
made this happen in my life along with
me working
uh as hard as i have is it's bigger than
it's bigger than i am
and fame is is the vehicle from which i
get to
have this platform so do i like that
i appreciate it if i had been what i
thought i was going to be
and that is a great fourth grade teacher
i would have also liked that because and
at the core of me i
am a teacher and i am happiest when i
feel
that people are getting something
learning
something enhancing themselves in a way
that they never thought of before that's
really truly one of my
favorite moments on television or in any
experience when
i'm just one-on-one with a friend or
somebody i don't even know being able to
share something with them and they think
i never
thought of it like gee rule number 17
provide value steadman and i were in a
hotel
watching some bad television and
i was complaining about the state of
television talk shows in particular
and he said why don't you change it why
don't you just get your own network
and i thought that that was a ridiculous
idea and then he started to talk about
it and he wrote some things down
and uh i saw the word own i thought oh
no w
oh that's my those are my initials and i
said wouldn't it be something if i could
create a network that was really about
mindful and i underlined the word
mindful
television fifteen years later those
scribblings came closer to reality
when she was approached by david zaslow
the president of the discovery network
my view was if we want to do this you
have to be all in she paused
and then she said to me uh it's meant to
be
and we shook hands and that's how our
journey began
at first i thought great a network oh
gee this is the dream i had oh
and i actually showed him the piece of
paper where i'd written it down instead
and as that started to settle in with me
i thought whoa what is this i've gotten
myself into this is a lot more work than
i ever
imagined are you scared very scared
i was very scared and i would wake up in
the middle of the night
literally like clutching my chest
like what have i done what have i done
what if you fail
that's what i was afraid of that's what
i was afraid of
the reason why i made the decision to go
forward
is because i believe
that people deserve to have
value-centered inspirational programming
for themselves
i believe that television has become in
many ways
banal it has become
insipid and um not ever not all of it
but i think that i have something to
offer rule number 18
don't give up i did this at the end of
my uh
uh show i did my favorite guest of all
times
that's hard to do out of literally
thousands and thousands they supposedly
estimated that there's like
35 000 people i interviewed over the
years but there was one woman
out of all the celebrities out of all of
the
famous non-famous infamous people one
woman from who is she her name is
tarai trent listen to the story
i'm going to try to shorten it for you
guys okay
tara right trent born and raised in a
village in zimbabwe
11 years old she's doing her brother's
homework she wants to go to school her
father says no
you're a girl you have to educate the
boy yes that's right
that's right the boy has to go to school
you can't go to school so she starts
doing her brother's homework
she does his brother's homework he goes
to school he gets all a's on his
homework yet he doesn't know the answer
to the question the teacher comes to the
village to say
what is going on here this boy doesn't
know the answers but his homework's
perfect
she finds out that tarai his younger
sister is doing his homework she begs
the father to let tararai go to school
the father says no she can't go to
school
finally he marries her off she marries
at 11 and a half years old
she gets married she has three children
by the time she's 18 years old
a woman comes to the village from an ngo
heifer international and asks what are
your dreams this is going to make me cry
finally cry ask her what are your dreams
this child has never thought about what
her dreams were she says write down your
dreams
she writes down her dreams on a piece of
paper and she folds them in a tin can
and she buries them
under a rock the first dream was to be
able to go to the school and
go to a school in the united states of
america
and get a college degree she ends up
through some miracle of the ngo
going to the united states she gets
a college degree wow yes she gets a
four-year degree in three years
terrorized trend she goes back to the
rock in zimbabwe
she writes her next goal on the piece of
paper
she buries it under the rock she writes
i want to get a master's degree
she goes back to uni and said she gets a
master's degree
by this time she now has five children
she's married to a man who still beats
her
incredible she goes back united said she
gets her master's degree
after the master's degree she goes back
to the rock in zimbabwe
she writes down her final goal is to get
a doctorate degree
and last year she became dr tararai
trent where did you find it where did i
find it um
i found her in the in the
nicholas kristoff's book called uh
something the sky underneath the sky or
this guy
nick i found her in nicholas christoph's
book
and i was reading the story i had
nicholas kristoff on the show nicholas
kristoff the famous new york times
writer and
she wasn't there she wasn't a part of
the ch i'm reading the story i can't
believe
this book the story of this woman as i'm
reading the story so when we go to do
the show
the producers have nicholas kristoff on
they bring on other guests
but this woman isn't there i go how
could you not have her there
so we tape another show with nicholas
kristoff we go back and go find we're
going to find that woman
terrorized trent this time by this time
she's living in the united states
we followed her back to zimbabwe to the
rock
we pulled the tin can from underneath
the rock
and that is my favorite guest of all
time and the worst um
i don't have a worst i don't have a
worse but the reason why she
and as i said this on my show the reason
why tara wright trent
is my favorite guest of all time is
because she represents
in that one story of the little girl in
a village in zimbabwe
who had a dream and the heart
and depth and discipline to pursue it
she represents
everything i tried to say in every show
in 25 years she literally through her
life story
sums up the message that i was trying to
give to
every single one of my viewers you can
you can keep trying don't give up
you have to believe you have to believe
rule number 19
live in the now the thing that i do best
piers
you didn't ask me that question oprah
what is it you do best
oprah what is it you do best the thing
that i
that i i strive to do best is be here
be now right here right now
with you the reason why we've had such a
good time is because i'm not thinking
about
somebody else's but i'm not thinking
about how much time do we have left and
how many questions you have and what are
you going to ask me
just be here be now so that i can enjoy
this experience and so um
i don't have a lot of i don't live in
the past i don't carry the past
into this moment because i do the oprah
show i learned how not to do that
that's what all of those years of
non-therapy but
paying attention to the guests on the
show the way they live their lives
what the experts had to say what i've
learned from paying
attention rule number 20 have fun
have you ever seen her before does she
look like oprah winfrey to you she does
that's her
tv one but don't tell anyone we're here
okay what's the zip code
i have been talking to people my whole
life
and nobody has ever said you be the
penis this is a letter i wrote to
anthony odie
i was such a geek
it says on today june 22nd 1971
i've decided to voice my thoughts on
paper to
to prevent my brain from becoming
disrupted
voice my thoughts on paper
that was in high school that was in high
school june 22nd okay
[Music]
she's always been very dramatic don't
you today is my ninth anniversary with
anthony nine months today
never thought i'd make it this far my
father says oh there we were
there's me with the flip that was the
marlo thomas that girl flip
my father says stay at home and rest
doesn't he know that love knows no
rest
nice vest anthony that for those who
love
time is not i love anthony i really
truly truly love him truly truly truly
and i don't give a blank i use the
blanks in case my father ever found the
letters i wouldn't be cursing
whether or not people think it's proper
or whether i'm too aggressive or flipped
for him
because i don't think god will mine
there's so
there's so much hatred in the world i
should think god would be happy to see a
little love flowing every now and then
rule number 21 set boundaries you know
because when i first started making
money
and it was you know my salary or my
earnings
were published all over the place i mean
the first year i was like really did i
make that much money oh my god
um it was very difficult for me to
figure out where my boundaries were
because i'd grown up poor and didn't
have anything
so it's easy when you don't have
anything and people ask you for money
they say i need 500 you say i don't have
it because i'm just trying to get my
rent paid
it's harder when your multi-billion
dollar salary is now in the paper and
you get a lot of friends and cousins you
didn't have before
so how do you set boundaries for
yourself i was having trouble setting
boundaries myself
for myself for even strangers people
would just show up at my door in chicago
and say oh bro i left my husband please
help me
and i would because she knows i haven't
so don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
so what i learned was is that oh the
reason why people keep showing up is
because
my intention is to make them think that
i'm such a nice person
that you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm gonna
say yes i'm gonna say
yes so when stevie called me this time
i thought i'd try out my first no on
stevie
let's start big he wanted me to donate
some money to a charity
and i didn't want to donate to the
charity because
i have my own charities and i care about
a lot of people but the
the problem is when you you have money
everybody thinks you just want to give
to everything so every letter i ever get
starts with
we know you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is going to have to help the
children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
and um as a person who has that disease
to please i was waiting for him then
just to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a song for you
and he didn't he just said okay
okay okay it's okay
he said okay check you later and
[Music]
what i learned from that is many times
you will have
angst and worry about things
put yourself in a state like someone
said this morning because their phone
went off they were mortified
over a phone i said really um you will
put yourself in a state when the other
person really isn't even thinking about
you
so learning that i could
specifically determine for myself
what the boundaries were for me
what i wanted to do give my money
give my time give of my service to who i
wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week
doesn't mean you have to try to fulfill
all of that
just because you have all of these
demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you
have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest henley said
in invictus and understanding that
really changed the meaning of my life in
that i was not
no longer driven by what other people
wanted me to do but took charge of my
own destiny
making choices based upon what do i feel
is the next right move for me
rule number 22 create the life you want
quincy jones had i would not even say an
important role i would say
the role in my acting career quincy
jones discovered me
and it's so interesting to me because
when i was uh working as a television
news woman in baltimore
and really all i wanted to do was be in
actors but i was
doing television and i felt at the time
like i can't quit this job because this
is what everybody else wants to do
and if i quit this job what am i going
to do
um and i was going to a speech coach at
the time that the station had sent me to
they
you know they have the broadcasting
school they sent everybody the same
woman
and i was telling her you know i really
don't want to do this what i really want
to do
is act and she says my dear you don't
want to act because if you wanted to act
you'd be doing it
what you want to be my dear is a star
because um
if you wanted to act you'd be waiting
tables in new york you'd be and i
thought now why am i going to wait
tables if i'm already working in tv
so i said well what i think is going to
happen
is i will be discovered because i want
it so badly somebody's going to have to
discover me
and she said you just dream you dream
you're a dreamer so when it happened
i called her up i said you will not
believe this
i got discovered and it really was a
discovery it's like one of those
lana turner stories only um wasn't a
drugstore he was uh in his hotel room
saw me on tv it was unbelievable the
interesting thing about that is that
i i truly believe that
thoughts are the greatest vehicle
to change power and success in the world
everything begins with thoughts i mean
the chairs that we're sitting in the
room that we're in
all started because somebody thought it
so i thought up the color purple for
myself
i know this is going to sound strange to
you i read the book
i i got so many copies of that book i
passed the book around
everybody i knew if i was on the bus i'd
pass it out to people
and when i heard that there was going to
be a movie i started
i started talking it up for myself i
didn't know quincy jones or steven
spielberg
or how on earth i would get in this
movie i've never acted in my life
but i i felt it so intensely that i had
to be a part of that movie i just
i i really do believe i created it for
myself i wanted it more than
anything in the world and would have
done anything to do it
anything to do it rumor 23 turn your
wounds
into wisdom turn your wounds into wisdom
you will be wounded many times in your
life you'll make mistakes
some people will call them failures but
i have learned that failure
is really god's way of saying excuse me
you're moving in the wrong direction
it's just an experience
just an experience just an
experience i remember being taken off
the air
in baltimore being told that i was no
longer be
being fit for television and that i
could not anchor the news because i used
to go out on the stories
and my own truth was even though i'm not
a weeper
i would cry for the people in the
stories and uh
which really wasn't very effective as a
news reporter to be covering a fire
and uh crying because the people lost
their house
um and it wasn't until
they i was demoted as a on-air anchor
woman
and thrown into the talk show arena to
get rid of me
that i allowed my own truth to come
through and the first day i was on the
air
doing my first talk show back in 1978 it
felt like breathing
which is what your true passion should
feel like it should be so
natural to you and so i took what had
been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career
as an anchor woman in the news business
and turned it into a talk show career
that's
done okay for me rule number 24
live your life to the fullest what
drives you to keep working so hard you
could
you know you and i are in the 60s
category
and so when you're in your 60s you know
you've lived more than you're going to
live
yeah realistically so when you realize
you've lived more than you're going to
live you can say why not
relax a little bit why not just ease up
why have you decided to even work harder
than you did before
because i think david that everybody you
know the thing that worked for me
all these years whether it was the
magazine or
which i still have or whether it was
the show i could i understood that
there's a common denominator in the
human experience
and i want the same thing you want which
is the same thing you want and you want
what we all want
is to be able to live out
the truest highest expression of
ourselves
as a human being that doesn't end until
you take your last breath
what is the truest highest vision that
you hold for yourself
no matter where you are in your life
there's always the next level there's
always the next level
to the last breath so i feel that i
always
knew that i would get be done with the
show when i felt like
oh i've said as much as i could say here
on this platform and then how will i be
used if there were
if there were a theme song to my life
amazing grace would be one of them
and keep on using me to use me up would
be another one
you know that bill with her song
so i feel that until you have used your
value as a human being you're not done
rule number 25
demand respect when i first
started as a broadcaster i was 19 very
insecure thrown
into television pretending to be barbara
walters looking nothing like her
and still going to college so i do all
my classes in the morning
from eight to one and then the afternoon
i work from two to ten
and did the six o'clock news and would
stay up and study and all that stuff
you know until one two or three o'clock
in the morning and then just start the
routine all over again
and my classmates were so jealous of me
that i remember like
taking my little 115 paycheck and
um at the time i thought it was really a
lot but
taking 115 and trying to appease them i
would like
oh anytime anybody needing money i was
always offering oh you need ten dollars
or taking them out for pizza ordering
pizza for the class and things like that
trying to that whole disease to please
that's where it was the worst for me i
think because
i wanted to be accepted by them and
could not be because
first of all i didn't have the time they
wanted wanted me to pledge and i didn't
have the time to pledge i was
i didn't have the time to be a part of
all the other college activities are a
part of that whole
lifestyle and it was very difficult for
me socially really one of the worst
times of my life because i was trying to
fit in
in school and be a part of that culture
but also trying to build a career
in television it's very difficult for me
to even
see myself as successful because i still
see myself as in the process
of becoming successful to me successful
is getting to the point where you are
absolutely comfortable with yourself
and it does not matter how many things
you have acquired
the ability to learn to say no and not
to feel guilty about it
to me is about the greatest success i
have achieved
the fact that i have you know in the
public side done whatever
is fine it's all a part of a process for
for growing for me
but to me to have the in the kind of
internal strength
and internal courage it takes to say no
i will not let you treat me this way
is what success is all about it's the
same thing that prevents
you from being abused as a child that
prevents you from being abused as an
adult
that allows you to build success for
yourself i will not be treated this way
i demand
only the best for myself you are worthy
to say no
your word that it's okay if you say no
it's okay if you say no and then people
don't like you
that's really okay the important thing
is how you
feel about what you're doing how you
feel about yourself
it's a long struggle though it's a long
struggle
and i'm just hoping that you know in the
works that i do on the show
and the speaking that i do around the
country and that
young people who are watching this can
get the lesson sooner than i did
because it's painful because you keep
repeating it over and over and over
until you get it right and what i found
is that every time you have to repeat
the lesson
it gets worse because it's you know it's
i i call it
god trying to get your attention the
universe trying to get your attention so
we didn't get your attention the first
time so we're gonna have to hit you a
little harder this time so
i'm still doing it i'm still learning
rule number 26 you become what you
believe
create the highest grandest
vision possible for your life because
you become what you believe when i was a
little girl
mississippi growing up on the farm only
buckwheat is a role model
watching my grandmother boil clothes in
a big iron pot through the screen door
because
we didn't have a washing machine and
made everything we had
i watched her and realized somehow
inside myself and the spirit of myself
that although this was segregated
mississippi
and i was colored and
female that my life could be bigger
greater than what i saw i remember being
four or five years old i certainly
couldn't articulate it but it was a
feeling
and a feeling that i allowed myself to
follow
i allowed myself to follow because if
you were to ask me what is the secret
to my success it is because i understand
that there is a power
greater than myself that rules
my life and in life
in life if you can be still long enough
in in all of your endeavors the good
times the hard times
to connect yourself to the source
i call it god you can call it whatever
you want to the force nature
allah the power if you can connect
yourself to the source and allow the
energy that is your personality
your life force to be connected to the
greater force
anything is possible for you
i am proof of that i think that my life
the fact that i was
born where i was born in the time that i
was and have been able to do what i've
done
speaks to the possibility not that i am
special
but that it could be done rule number 27
touch lives every day i remember when i
started the school and i said to my
uh beloved friend maya angelou i said
maya
i'm so i'm just so proud that i was able
to create the school and i said this is
going to be my greatest legacy
and maya said to me you have no idea
all right you have no idea
what your legacy will be she said to me
because your legacy
is every life you've touched and that
shifted
the way i saw legacy or what you leave
behind or what you do
because maya was explaining to me that
you know
over all the years of watching your show
everybody who decided that they were
going to go back to school or lose
weight
or no longer hit their children or get
out of a bad marriage
all of those people who have seen and
experienced your voice
and the same thing with everybody here
you have no idea
what your legacy will be your legacy
is every life that you've touched and we
like to think of it i know
you have done amazing things with your
philanthropy
we like to think that these great
philanthropic moments
are the ones that leave the impact or
will make the huge difference in the
world but it's really what you do
every day it's how you use your life
to be a light to somebody else's
you know and it's how you use your work
as an
expression of your own art whatever that
is
rule number 28 own your life my
intention in creating masterclass
came from the understanding that
everybody's story
is the same all stories are connected
and there is nothing that anyone who's
living on earth
has ever felt or known or experienced on
a soul level
that hasn't been felt or known or
experienced by someone else
one of the most difficult things in life
is feeling that
you are the only one you are the only
one who's traveled this path who's felt
this way
i had nowhere to go i was homeless at
the time i lost my family
next thing i knew i'm in this car for
three years man i'm struggling
who's experienced such devastation or
joy
or triumph or victory so for me
i define a master as someone
who has fully stepped in
and owned the full
progress and trajectory of their life
persistence pays off that's lesson one
but hearing stories told from the mail
to people who
know how to live how to course correct
how to keep going how to never quit
how to rejoice in the good times
and have faith in the bad those people
are masters
anyone who can do that is a master and
their ability
to share their stories only helps
the trajectory of others who listen
rule number 29 live a truthful life
what i learned going to beauty salon and
asking them after the news director had
told me that my hair was too thick and
my
eyes were too far apart and i needed a
makeover and um
sitting in a beauty salon in a french
beauty salon allowing them to put a
french perm on my black hair
and having the perm burn through my
cerebral cortex
and not being the woman that i am now so
not having the courage to say
this is burning me
and coming out a week later bald and
having to go on the air
you learn a lot about yourself when
you're black and a woman and bald and
trying to be an anchor woman
you learn you learn you're not dying a
ross
and that you're not barbara walters
trying to be i was at the time
i had a lot of lessons i remember going
on the air many times and
not reading my copy ahead of time and i
was on the air one night and
ran across the word b-a-r-b-a-d-o-s
that may be barbados to you but it was
barbados to me that night
and telling the story as an anchor woman
about a vote
in abstentia california i thought it was
located near san francisco
and one of the worst one of the worst
this is one i broke out of my barber
shell because i'm sitting there crossing
my legs trying to talk like barbara be
like barbara
and uh i was reading a story about
someone with a
blaze attitude which
if i had gone to wellesley i would have
known it was blase
and i started to laugh at myself on the
air and broke through my barbara shell
and had decided on that day that
laughing was okay even though barbara
hadn't at that time
and it was through my series of mistakes
that i learned that i could be a better
oprah than i could be a better barber
and i allowed barbara to be the mentor
for me as she always has been and i
decided
then to try to pursue the idea of being
myself and i
am just thrilled that i get paid so much
every day for just
just being myself but it was a lesson
long in coming
recognizing that i had the instinct that
the inner voice
that told me that you need to try to
find a way
to answer to your own truth was the
voice i needed to be still and listen to
get this this is just remember this
because this will happen many times your
life
when people show you who they are
believe them the first time
not the 29th time
[Applause]
that's particularly good when it comes
to to men's situations
because when he doesn't call back the
first time
when you're mistreated the first time
when you see someone who shows you a
lack of integrity or dishonesty
the first time know that that will be
followed
by many many many other times that will
at some point in life come back to haunt
or hurt you
when people show you who they are
believe them
the first time live your life from a
point of view of truth and you will
live your life from truth and you will
survive
everything everything i believe even
death
you will survive everything if you can
live your life from a point of view of
truth
rule number 30 say thank you close your
eyes
for a moment will you please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will
put your thumb to your middle finger
and gather your other fingers around and
let's feel
the vibration and pulse of your personal
energy
as you take three deep breaths with me
inhale
and as you exhale just feel
the vibration energy
blood pulsating through
your body through you and another inhale
and another inhale
ah and keep your eyes closed
and let's just think about
this day
this day that you have been graced
to breathe
in and out thousands of times
this day where many of those breaths
were taken for granted you just
expected the next one to come
but the truth is there's no guarantee
that the next one comes
this day how you started your day what
your thoughts were this morning
how you've carried yourself through this
day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences
challenging some more life enhancing
that push you forward another day
of being here on the planet earth
as a human being
let's just think about that after all
you've been through
in this day alone
and the many days and years passed
how you got here to this prestigious
esteemed university
the choices you made that have brought
you to
this day
open your heart
and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer that's ever needed
thank you
thank you
thank you
you're still here
and you get another chance this day
to do better and be better
another chance to become more of who
you were created
and what you were created to fulfill
thank you rule number 31 master your
craft
and the number one lesson i could offer
you where your work is concerned is this
become so skilled so vigilant
so flat out fantastic
at what you do that your talent cannot
be dismissed stop comparing yourself
to other people
[Applause]
you're only on this planet to be you
not someone else's imitation of you i
had to learn that the hard way
on the air live anchoring the news
one night in my 20s when i first started
broadcasting i was 19 moved to an anchor
by the time i was 20
and i was just pretending to be barbara
walker walters i was just
trying to talk like barbara act like
barbara hold my legs like barbara
and i was on the air and i hadn't read
the copy fully and i called
canada canada and
i did that on the air i cracked myself
up because i thought barbara would never
call canada kanada
and that little breakthrough that little
crack that little moment
that i stopped pretending allowed the
real
me to come through your life journey is
about learning to become more of who you
are and fulfilling the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being
that's why you're here rule number 32
find a way to serve
number two you
must find a way to serve
martin luther king said that not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined
by service now we live in a world where
everybody wants to be famous
and where we admire people for just
being famous we think being known
brings us value the truth is all of that
will fade in time in three years you
won't be able to name the housewives
of atlanta
[Music]
the real truth is that
service and significance
service and the significance that you
bring to your service
is that which is lasting so to be able
to whatever
your occupation or job or talent or
gift is our honorees today
getting doctor degrees to
apparently opposite fields hiv and aids
and the spoken word but what they have
in common
is service using the spoken word
in service to community and the world
using your knowledge and information
about hiv and aids and medicine
in service to the world and if you look
at all the most
successful people in the world whether
they know it or not
they have that paradigm of service
everybody's talking about mark
zuckerberg and ipo
service jay-z rapid
service through the word to people
through song for many years i was really
just happy to be on
tv and people would stop and say oh you
on tv yeah i'm on tv
i like being on tv it's a nice job
and it was about the time that i
received my
honorary doctorate from spelman around
1993 so i don't know if that had
something to do with it i thought of
myself as dr winfrey
that i went back and i took a long look
at what it was i was doing on
on tv and made a decision
that i was no longer going to just be on
tv
but i was going to use tv
as a platform as a force for good
and not be used by tv
and i will tell you
my decision to make that
significant change in the way i operated
on television using television as a
service
changed my career exponentially
[Music]
service through medicine service through
art using whatever it is
you produce your product as a way
of giving back to the world when you
shift the paradigm of whatever it is you
choose to do
to service and you bring significance to
that
success will i promise you
follow you service and significance
equals success that's number two
rule number 33 take responsibility you
are responsible for your life
and if you're sitting around waiting on
somebody to save you
to fix you to even help you
you are wasting your time because only
you
have the power to take responsibility
to move your life forward and the sooner
you get that
the sooner your life gets into gear what
matters
is now this moment and your willingness
to see this moment for what it is accept
it
forgive the past take responsibility
and move forward rule number 34 solve
problems you build a legacy
not from one thing but from everything
i remember when i just opened my school
in 2007 i came back and i had the
great joy of sitting at my angelou's
table she hadn't been able to attend the
opening in south africa and i said to
her
oh maya the oprah winfrey leadership
academy that's going to be my greatest
legacy i remember she was standing at
the counter making biscuits and she
turned
she put the dough down and she looked at
me and she said
you have no idea what your legacy will
be
said excuse me i just opened the school
and these girls and it's going to be and
she said
you have no idea
what your legacy will be because your
legacy
is every life you touch
every life you touch
that changed me
[Music]
and it's true you can't personally stop
anybody from walking into a school with
an assault rifle
nor can you single-handedly ensure that
the rights that your mothers and your
grandmothers fought so hard for
will be preserved for the daughters that
you may someday have
and it'll take more than you alone to
pull 40 million americans out of poverty
but who will you be if you don't care
enough to try
and what mountains could we move i think
what gridlock
could we eradicate if we were to join
forces and work together in service of
something greater than ourselves
you know my deepest satisfaction and my
biggest
rewards have come from exactly that
pick a problem any problem
and do something about it because to
somebody
who's hurting something
is everything rule number 35 always do
the right thing always do
the right thing
always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be excellent people notice
think of how you notice you go to taco
bell somebody gives you extra napkin and
some sauce
you notice you want to go back to that
person
because even at taco bell excellence
shows itself be excellent let
excellence be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand i
never even knew what that was
when people would say your brand i would
say no i'm just oprah
what i recognize now is that my choice
to in every way in every example
in every experience to do the right
thing
and the excellent thing is what has
created
the brand
years ago i did an ad for revlon for
uh for an ad they were doing called
unforgettable women and what i know
is that when you are excellent
you become unforgettable
people remember you you stand out
regardless of what it is
you become an unforgettable woman and
that is what we all want
we want to be unforgettable and not
forgettable
so doing the right thing even
when nobody knows you're doing the right
thing
will always bring the right thing to
you i promise you that why
because the third law of motion is
always at work for every action there's
an equal and opposite reaction
that is so true in all of our lives
rule number 36 listen to the universe
the universe speaks to us always
first in whispers
[Music]
and a whisper usually in your life feels
like
that's odd or
that doesn't make any sense or
is that right it just really feels like
that it's that it's that kind of subtle
and if you don't pay attention to the
whisper it gets louder
and louder and louder and i say it's
like getting thumped upside the head
you don't pay attention to that it's
like getting a brick upside your head
you don't pay attention to that the
brick wall falls down
that is the pattern that i see in
my life in so many other people's lives
and so i ask people
what are the whispers what's whispering
to you now
and can you catch it in the whisper rule
number 37 become the best version of
yourself
i have paid attention to my life
because i understand that my life just
like your life
is always speaking to you where you
are in the language with the people
with the circumstances and experiences
that you can understand
and interpret if you are willing to see
that always life
god is speaking to you
now it took me a while to actually
really
get this and to understand it but once i
did
i started paying attention to everything
and one of the reasons why i can now
accept the fact
that i can offer my
gatherings of information and wisdom and
call myself a spiritual teacher
is that every single person whoever came
on my show and i hear there's like
37 000 guests i've talked to
a lot of them came from dysfunction and
a lot of them wouldn't appear to be
teachers but every one of them had
something to say
that was meaningful and valuable and
that i could use
to grow myself into
the best of myself which is what all of
our jobs are
your number one job is to become more of
yourself
and to grow yourself into the best of
yourself
rule number 38 surround yourself with
great people
people don't always like you and they're
not always happy for you
and if you surround yourself with people
who are not accustomed
to your success they become
fearful they become scared
because you are reflecting back
something to them that they don't
recognize
now they're not going to say
you know i'm very fearful
because you're reflecting back to me
something i don't recognize
they're going to say you know what
they're going to say
they're going to say who she thinks she
is
who she thinks she is that only happens
when you are around
people who do not mean and want
and aspire to the best for you
people who want the best for you want
you to
be your best so my greatest advice to
you
is to surround yourself with people who
are going to
fill your cup until your cup runneth
over
so when people say you're so full of
yourself you can say
[Music]
[Applause]
yes i'm full
i'm so full my cup runneth over
and to know that once your cup runneth
over
you cannot spend your life
with your gallon size
offerings offering them to pint-sized
people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have got to surround yourself with
gallon-sized
people who can hang in the same company
with you
so that you're not offering your gallons
to those little pipes out there
who can't hold it anyway rule number 39
find your true passion if you can find
what is your passion if you
find what you love you never get tired
or if you do get tired
you you're fueled by the energy of your
work
and you know what you're supposed to do
but how it feels
and so you know if you're doing the
right thing if it feels like it's right
to you and when you hit the thing that
feels right
you know it's right because it gives you
your juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue that's
how you know you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing
rule number 40 have fun oprah you're so
recognizable are you ever able to sneak
out like disguise
oh do you ever go out oh no i i well
the the last time i had on a hat and
glasses somebody said to me what are you
trying to do be
incognito but do i have time for this
really funny story sure so i'm walking
my dogs
in chicago and i have my hair this is
during the summer
uh several years ago my hair is
cornrowed and i'm walking
and so there's this kind of like
homeless guy and i'm going past the park
and the guy goes
how you doing baby
he goes what's your name so i ignored
him ignored him you know keep walking he
goes
what you can't tell about your name so i
turned around and i said
oprah winfrey and he goes you wish
rule number 41 know who you are for me
the foundational
base of empowerment of
entrepreneurship of any kind of
engagement
the foundational base of my success
of my well-being my wholeness
my everything is knowing who
i am and where i come from
[Music]
in my living room right now is a
painting that i've owned now for 30
years
you can google it it's called to the
highest
bidder and it's at the center of my
house
and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic
of the foundation of not the house but
the foundation for my life
the painting is by harry rosalind who
was a genre painter painter
in the uh early 20th late 19th century
and the painting's over six feet tall
and it shows
a slave woman on the auction block
holding her daughter's hand and i cannot
come in the door
my front door or i cannot leave without
passing that painting i am reminded of
where i come from
every day of my life and i am reminded
because i never want to forget it
and in my library i have a framed list
of enslaved african-american people
remember i showed you
who were held in bondage on various
plantations
listed in the ledgers alongside the cows
and the horses and the buggies and the
other property
and i pass this list every day and often
i stop in front of it and just
speak their names out loud
and their ages jonas
11 years old 500
sarah 41 years old
900 dollars elizabeth
57 800
and i forced myself to consider the
absurdity and the obscenity of
prices being affixed to each one should
they be placed up for sale
and i sometimes just pause before them
with a prayer
particularly before i have to make a big
decision about
one of my companies or whether i move
forward or whether i stay still
it reminds me speaking those names out
loud
not only of where i've come from but how
far
i have to go because of them and it
reminds me
that i am never alone it reminds me
of what i've come through to get through
rule number 42 be a warrior of the light
everybody is feeding yourself on
the hysteria and the negativity you
gotta stay
in the light but one of the reasons why
i was so excited is
about a wrinkle in time because the
message is that the darkness
is spreading so fast these days you must
become a warrior of the light
and the reason that's so meaningful to
me is because that's how i've led my
whole life
and every moment in that film i just
felt like i'm just saying what i've
normally said it's true and and for
these
times the darkness is there to show you
your light
look at what has happened so if you put
the focus on
look at what happened with the darkness
that showed up in parkland
and the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson the darkness
that showed up in many many many many
many many homes
in chicago with shootings and uh
senseless murders
it brings out the best in people it
brings out the best and so that's what
it's there we live on a planet where
there is darkness
and light what i deeply believe is not
that do unto others as you would have
them do unto you
what you do is already done that moment
in the color purple where she says
everything you ever tried to do to me
where whoopi says that and silly
everything you ever
everything you even try to do to me
already done to you
so the law the third law of motion in
physics says
that what you're putting out is coming
back
all the time regardless of whether you
know it or acknowledge it or not
so you got to stay as a warrior rule
number 43
know your strengths you've done
magazines you've done movies you've done
television
have you ever wanted to release a cd of
music oh honey please
no no i
you know what i think one of the things
i learned growing up watching other
people
like johnny carson for example was um
was a mentor in a way because he always
understood what he could and could not
do
and i truly understand
that that is not something i could do i
mean i attempted it just as a fun thing
a couple years ago run on run on i got
sick of hearing myself that's why we
that's why we cut it off i wished i
could it's the one thing i wish i could
do but i think it's a gift
to be able to sing and that's not what i
was given but
since i was given so many others rule
number 44
earn success my biggest frustration is
not just with young women my biggest
frustration is also with young men young
people
who think that and i have a lot of this
with my
girls in college they think
that success is supposed to happen like
that
yeah they think that
there isn't a process to it they
think that they're supposed to come out
of college and have their brand
and um i recognize now that i
am a brand but i was resistant to being
called a brand for many years because i
was like i'm a brand
i'm not a brand i'm a person but how i
got to be a brand was not trying to be a
brand
how i got to be a brand was every day
making choices
that felt like this is the right move
now that's the right move
and now that's the next right move the
next right move and so my frustration
with young women and young men
is that they think it's supposed to
happen like this and they don't
understand that there's a process to it
social media
it's social media you did not get to be
editor of vogue magazine
by not working and working and working
and working and working to get here
i love the theory of that there's 10 000
hours behind anybody who ever gets to be
successful
rule number 45 have good instincts
i was interviewing a woman uh on one of
the shows it was so impressive for me to
see all the shows that we've done lord
made me tired looking at it
but i was interviewing a woman it was a
show called
the mistress the wives meet the
mistresses or some
crazy thing and this woman was on and
it was a live show and in the middle of
it her husband
tells the wife and our entire audience
and the world
that his mistress was pregnant
yes to this day makes my eyes water
because
i saw his wife's face
and i felt her humiliation
and i said i will quit tv if i have to
do this i won't do this anymore
and my producer's like what are we going
to do this is what everybody's doing
and then that same during that same time
period
so i said i'm not going to do anything
like that anymore i'm not going to
not going to bring people on tv first of
all we didn't know that moment was going
to happen they were like we didn't know
what's going to happen
but that should not happen on television
and i do not want to be a part of the
energy that caused somebody to feel that
because that's not going to come back to
me i got to pay for that
then i was interviewing the kkk on stage
that was the day the one guy called me a
monkey in the audience
and during commercial break i could see
them signaling each other
and just watching them and their
behavior
i thought oh they get it i don't get it
they are using me they are using this
platform
because they understand because i'm
thinking oh i'm going to tell you all
about the kkk
they were using it to recruit members
for themselves
they were using it to recruit their base
and i then went to the producers except
not doing a show like that so they said
you're not going to do the mistresses
you know
you're not going to do it what we gonna
do
so i said we we are going to
um create a baseline for ourselves
that's based on intention this was
around 1989 when i read gary zhukov's
book
called the seat of the soul and that
book was life-changing for me
because in it he talked about the power
of intention
and that cause and effect
what goes out comes back is determined
by your intention the energy of your
intention
is what determines your life most people
don't think about their intention they
just think about what they want to do
most people don't think about why they
want to do it but what's going to come
back to you the energy that's going to
come back to you
is the real why of why you did it
and so i then said to my producers we're
not going to do any shows that are not
intentional so don't bring me an idea
unless you have an intention for the
show that you want the outcome to be and
we're going to
strive to see if we can live up to
our intentions and so around the late
80s we started a pre-show to talk about
what the intention was
and then a post show after every single
show to say did we fulfill that
intention
and that's about the time i realized
this is bigger than me
rule number 46 love your audience
i actually miss i miss you guys yeah
i don't i i miss you guys because
where i got fed every day was the
audience and i did not
miss a day in 25 years
because of the audience i don't care how
badly i felt i don't care
what kind of cold what kind of flu i
would come because
i knew that i you know our ira in our
audience every day we're
a couple hundred 350 people every day
who have literally told their aunts
their cousins they came with their
mothers they came with their friends
and i know that the preparation to get
there you've been coming from iowa we've
been coming from tennessee
for days so it's not just a oh i'm just
going to oprah's show you tell that girl
i'm going to open it
rule number 47 just be yourself
the beauty of my life edward is that
from i'd say 32 33 on
i figured out how to be myself
completely on television and all these
years
i have made a fortune really being
myself
so i'm never not me i'm never not the
person
that you see you know there are days
when i am more
open and warm than others and one of the
things that actually caused me
in 1998 to get my own
plane i was in the airport and i was
just
minding my own business and a woman came
up and she said you're not acting like
you do on tv
and i said what's that she says well on
tv you're hugging everybody and you're
just sitting here and you're not hugging
away i'm just sitting here man i'm just
waiting on the plane
so um if i'm in an airport i'm not
necessarily walking around hugging
people okay
but i am i am just always just myself
rule number 48 align yourself with your
dream
life has dreamed a dream for you and
your
your goal your number one job is to
figure out what that dream is
and align yourself with the dream
because the dream cannot come to you
unless you're willing to meet
it energetically in the same place
so if your energy is off which i say to
my girls all the time
they could teach this class right now on
being in flow
if you are not in flow with
god's dream for you with life's dream
for you if you
are out of order if you are out of sync
it cannot come to you it will not
come because the whole purpose of your
life
is to line yourself up with the purpose
and so if you are operating in fear
if you are operating in uh jealousy
jealousy will kill you when you are
synced up with life
life just gives to you it opens doors
it creates experiences it allows you to
meet people
things show up you never thought were
going to show up
and you are doing what
is the purpose of your soul being here
rule number 49 create a meaningful life
you know i believe that the common
thread that flows between
and through and around every person is
that we all have
this deep desire within us to create a
meaningful life it's like a yearning
that we all have to be more alive and to
express
ourselves and as you think of what
lasting fulfillment looks like for you
remember that this force
whatever name you may call it
is at work within you and all of us
and it has a bigger dream for you than
you could ever imagine for yourself
and rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun i'm really interested in my
classes seeing this now somebody's cell
phone it is like playing a little melody
let's hear it bring it over here come on
come on come on
come on come on down who are you calling
um elaine is it
elaine who just called you yes
you know i and i actually called her to
say no she wanted to go on the show
she didn't return my coffee she's
calling now is she answering
elaine
um elaine this is not a good time to
have coffee
elaine elaine this is oprah winfrey and
you call
your friend while she's sitting in the
middle of an oprah winfrey show
did you not know she was coming to the
open show
no well this she's sitting here right
now and
she cannot believe that you called her
at this time
where where are you where are you elaine
did you know anna she tried to call you
early girl to come to oprah show
and you did not call her back and so now
you're calling her while she's sitting
up here on the show
[Applause]
you know but well no we're not on the tv
now we're we're we taped the show the
show's gone
what time is it this is true of course
it is it sounds like me
of course it is no i wouldn't i wouldn't
kid you with something like that but
anyway
sorry you missed today we were giving
away so much stuff
now i've got a really special bonus clip
from oprah on how to rise that i think
you're going to really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking
action in your life or your business and
if you're feeling bold
answer the questions in the comments
below here we
go question number one what's the best
way that you can serve
others number two what do you need to
take responsibility for
in your life and number three who are
you going to say thank you to
today
you can use your gifts that's what
you're really here to do
to illuminate the darkness in our world
so this is what i also know that this
this this moment in time
this is your time to rise
it is even though
you can't go anywhere you can't stand in
line at starbucks you can't go to a
party
you can go to any place without
everywhere you turn
people are talking about how bad things
are how terrible it is
and this is what i know the problem is
everybody is meeting hysteria with more
hysteria
and then we just are all becoming
hysterical and it's getting worse
what i've learned all these years is
that we're not supposed to
match it or even get locked into
resisting
or pushing against it we're supposed to
see
this moment in time for what it is
we're supposed to see through it and
then transcend it
that is how you overcome asteria
and that is how you overcome the sniping
at one another
the trolling the mean-spirited
partisanship
on both sides of the aisle the
divisiveness the injustices
and the out and out hatred
you use it use this moment
to encourage you to embolden you and to
literally push you into the rising
of your life and to borrow a phrase from
my
beloved mentor maya angelou just like
moons
and like suns with the certainty of
tides
just like the hopes springing high you
will rise raise your standard
apple at the core its core value
is that we believe that people
with passion can change the world to the
best
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance to me
if you want more oprah check out the
video i did on her on her six
pieces of life-changing advice the link
is right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there not everybody can be famous but
everybody can be great because greatness
is determined
by service